writer eege Carroll will testify in the
second damages trial against former
president Trump who was found to have
sexually abused and defamed her last
year you see how they wrote that yeah
the implication of course being that
last year Donald Trump sexually
assaulted a woman oh jeez read it you
see how NBC News wrote it right was
found to have sexually abused and
defamed her last year yeah should say
who was last year comma found to have
abused her and if want to be if you
actually want to write real news you
would say writer EEG Carol will testify
in the second damag his trial against
President Trump who was found in a trial
last year to have sexually abused her in
the 1990s dude this is NBC man that's
gruesome NBC that's not surprising they
are the most evil propaganda uh um smear
Merchants that we have their whole their
whole disinformation news team where
even 538 Nate silver a bunch of other
journalists and Jay like J professors
constantly call out the NBC News team
because they actually fabricate things
and win awards for doing it and then
people are like this is remarkable
they're just outright lying all the time
Clarity and accuracy are supposed to be
things that they go for like that's
supposed to be the the the point of of
Journalism and news is so that way they
can make things you know understandable
for the average person and they do
nothing of the sort me let me show you
this story from a post millennial Trump
dares judge in egene Carol defamation
case to kick him out of court he
actually did so uh the judge says Mr
Trump I hope I don't have to consider
excluding you from The Trial I
understand you are probably very eager
for me to do that Trump said I would
love it I would love it waving his hands
I can imagine he's going like this with
his hands I know you would because you
just can't control yourself in this
circumstance Trump says you can't either
the threat came after Carol's attorney
Shan Crowley had raised issue with Trump
speaking loudly potentially loud enough
to be heard by the jury the the court is
is not allowing Trump to provide
evidence that she is likely lying yeah
so like with Alex Jones this is what
they do they create a fake reason why
this is said and done you get no chance
to defend yourself and the the trial
you're actually allowed to argue is how
much money do you
owe so with Alex Jones they said he
defamed these families Jones's legal
team said Alex never actually called
them out by name he was vaguely
referring to people in these cases
and what happens is the court said turn
over these documents they do the court
says okay turn over the documents and
Alex goes I did and said no you didn't
well here are the documents again then
the court says if you don't turn over
those documents we're going to hold you
in default and so Alex's legal team goes
here are the documents here's all of
them here's everything and they go well
you didn't give us the documents default
judgment bang that's what happened to
Alex Jones so when they actually went to
trial the trial we saw was a was a was
to determine the amount Alex would oh
you didn't know that Phil no I didn't
know Jones never had a trial as to
whether or not he defamed the family I
didn't know that he gave them the
paperwork three times and they said no
you they kept saying you're excluding
documents you're not giving what giv us
what we asked for and Alex kept saying
I've given you everything I have nothing
else to give and they said summary
judgment for for the plaintiffs Alex
Jones the next court uh case we're going
to have is how much money you owe I had
so every time we watched a video clip of
Alex arguing he would say something like
I didn't do that stop you already been
found liable you cannot deny the
accusation now wow as to what we were
saying this is the game they're playing
you take a look at what they're doing in
the fraud case for for Donald Trump in
New York City the goal here is to strip
him of all of his assets yeah they
dissolved his company they ruled that
it's it's done summary judgment Trump
committed fraud over no defense Donald
Trump will not get a chance to defend
himself and prove his innocence no
matter what anyone says from this point
the court has already determined that
Trump has committed fraud now the the
court case we're going to have is did he
Forge business documents and how much
does he owe and what will the damages be
so then when Trump brings in financial
institution experts and things like that
who say not only did we make a lot of
money and not only did Donald Trump do
this literally everyone does it and
everyone is happy with it they go that's
fine it doesn't matter we've already
determined that he is liable for this
he's guilty so your your testimony is
meaningless because we are not here to
determine the guilt of Donald Trump
we've already determined that that's
what they're doing here so Trump telling
the judge speaking out and yelling
against him I mean we are we are already
at this point I was talking to a lawyer
uh a year two years ago maybe about
filing a lawsuit and what they said was
uh okay what state you're filing in you
file it in Maryland you'll lose Democrat
judges are going to laugh you laugh at
your face I said West Virginia and they
go oh okay yeah West Virginia you'll win
because conservative judges will will
agree with you and I was like that's
really it isn't it like oh venues
everything it used to be it it always
mattered so you'd figure out what's the
best venue for the lawsuit uh where you
have you have to have you have to have
standing they have to have the right
jurisdiction and then you want to find a
place where you're likely to get a good
judge who will agree with your arguments
nowadays it's Civil War baby I'm saying
that figuratively but it's basically
like if you are trying to sue a democrat
in a Democrat State you you're going to
lose just no question you walk in and
you're going to be like I have video
evidence of this guy smashing my car
with a sledgehammer screaming I am doing
this for no reason and and I will never
pay you back for it and the Jud go
interesting and you'll say the guy who
did it is wearing a a Biden shirt and
I'm wearing a trump hat he's going to be
like you know I just think that there's
more of the story so I'm going to
dismiss the case that's basically the
way the game is played now yeah so don't
bring up
politics I don't think there's anything
you can do about it yeah because as as
soon as if you get picked up for
anything the da is going to start
looking through your history well that's
criminal yeah yes but in in and and so
what happens there is like in DC with J
Sixers good luck facing down a DC
far-left jury you could prove
definitively I mean come on Jack bobic
gets punched by ntif fagy yeah police
witness it and then the anti people go I
didn't see anything nothing happened yep
you can you you will have a jury of your
pews in DC and they're all liberals and
there can be a video of you not of of
you proving your innocence and then
they're going to be but he's a trump
supporter and they're going to be he's
guilty lock him up we don't care the
prosecutors don't even file charges on
those incidents I mean even over weekend
when we saw in in front of the White
House I mean protesters the pro
Palestine protesters were literally
threatening to break into the White
House and shaking the fence to get in
and secret services on the other side
pushing it back zero yeah zero uh border
Hawk reported too that there was an
individual who pulled a knife and that
person zero still no arrest no arrest
and the doj didn't respond when I
reached out they don't care it's just
it's just different venues they just
don't care if you are if you have the
right politics you can get away with
almost anything and Republicans are are
just so weak yeah they don't I'm sorry
dude like this is why they say far right
and extremist because Republicans are
are basically like the Democrats gimps
yeah and the Democrats are dragging them
by the collar I'll give you an example
uh simple question and and I know Phil
knows the answer to this Phil does the
Second Amendment protect the right of
children to keep in bare
arms he has nodding yes well yeah yeah I
mean I thought you were asking for for
yes yes of course it does the answer is
yes
uh children have always had guns and the
issue now is not whether or not they
keep in arms but parental supervision
this is what happened with kitten housee
the law said that as a minor he was
allowed to keep and bear certain guns
certain other guns are regulated the
issue of Regulation that's been found in
the Supreme Court is that regulating
which weapons you can carry is not an
infringement on your constitutional
rights meaning children do have the
right to keep in be arms however the
Supreme Court recognizes restrictions on
how and when they can keep in be arms
the next question do private individuals
uh I should say this does the Second
Amendment guarantee the right of the
private individual in the United States
to keep in Bear nuclear
weapons the answer is yes because who do
you think makes them it is large private
corporations that manufacture all of
these missiles and warships and drones
the drones carrying the Hellfire
missiles they're not made by the
government they're made by private
corporations who own them and sell them
to the government second amendment
protects all of that so when people are
like the Second Amendment never
protected your right to of cannons what
are you talking about Boeing's got
Hellfire missiles is it Boeing that
makes the uh the reaper Dr Who makes the
Reaper drone locked Martin yeah me is it
locked all I know it's like dude it's
the military industrial complex
producing all these weapons and under uh
uh corporate law they are private
citizens they are private persons for
the purpose of
ownership atomics that builds the
general atomics mq9 Reaper there's a lot
of times where the military will go to
company and be like look this is a a a
goal that we have or a machine that we
want you to build but also there's a lot
of times where like the private sector
will build something and present it to
the dod and be like check out this
gadget that we came up with and the dod
is like check out these dollars we just
printed here take them the point here is
that I can talk to even the most Ardent
of Republican Congress people and they
will say no I I don't think people
should have the right to keep and Bar
nuclear weapons and I'm like okay so we
can start by shutting down the ability
of any private Corporation for building
a nuke only under strict government
control can weapons be manufactured like
let's look obviously nuke is Extreme and
uh uh you know the way you go about it
that anyone who who uh uh whenever we
have someone who's like a gun
manufacturer a gun shop owner FFL they
were like yeah there's a form you can
fill out for when you're making a weapon
if it's a nuclear weapon or not because
corporations do this so okay the idea
there would be if the Second Amendment
only protects the keeping and bearing of
arms like small guns and stuff we got to
shut down locky Martin Boeing Ron Etc
all of them just shut down overnight or
nationalize them that means all your
precious stock is gone and worthless
should we National well I guess they'll
buy you out but do we want to
nationalize these uh these military
industrial complex companies no we don't
yeah so uh unless any of these
individuals in Congress think we should
then they absolutely agree the second
amend protects those rights my point is
this Republicans are Democrats gimps
they're on leashes being dragged around
and it's fascinating when we have even
fre caucus individuals come in on this
show and they don't know these things
and I'm like if you're taking the
approach that private the Second
Amendment doesn't protect nuclear
weapons you are basically in the middle
you are a you are a moderate leftist in
terms of constitutionalism and there are
a lot of people who are like I'm
rightwing on the second amendment and
I'm like no you're not and uh we had
someone on the show who was like I will
not be out second amendment by Tim pool
or whatever it was really funny I think
it was a member I can't remember who it
was maybe you guys listening to but this
is my point when it comes to what we
know they are doing with the like the
Insurrection in front of the White House
that just happened this past weekend M
trying to rip down the barricades
pulling a knife or even the 529
Insurrection my point and why I bring
this up is that Republicans right now
could launch an investigation committee
into the Insurrection at the White House
today and say what is going on with this
and they have the perfect backdrop Pro
Hamas protesters yeah now of course you
could make the argument they're not
really my point is this
the j6 protesters weren't
insurrectionists but they say they are
why aren't Republicans coming out right
now passing all these resolutions
putting together committees saying we
must investigate the pramas cells of
far-left extremists that have just
attacked the white house because they're
weak and they will be weak and even the
ones that you think are good are still
middle of the road it's a lot of the
Republican party is a hold over from
when the Republicans were the War
Machine the military industrial complex
arm with the George Bush Jr era and then
Obama came in and they all kind of went
over to that Democratic party um so
that's I think that's why a lot of the
older people are still like beholden to
the military industrial complex I mean
the country is like a militra it's been
it's just like an arms dealer this
country is like we export military
equipment and and dollars backed by our
military and what else wheat sugar flour
and oil that's about it no I mean we we
export a whole lot more stuff just that
there's we export a lot more than that
we don't yeah we don't we don't export
as much as we used to but we definitely
export way more than just like a handful
of things thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net